Qu'est ce qu'il y a ?
En plus c'est David Stone !
*Rire*
Salut, aujourd'hui on est Lundi
et vous vous dites ''Dis donc"
"Il serait pas un petit peu habillé comme dimanche ?"
Avec les même lumières que Dimanche ?"
C'est vrai, parce que je fais un peu cette vidéo là dimanche.
Le lundi c'est le jour du vlog
et je vais vous mettre les rushs d'un Vlog
qui est sur un projet qui s'appelle "SECRET STUDIO"
qui est un projet
vraiment à la destination des mentalismes un peu confirmés
des magiciens un peu confirmés.
On a tournée dans un studio secret comme son nom l'indique.
Qu'est ce qu'on va faire ici ? Eh bien en fait, je vais donner une conférence ici
qui va être à priori filmée.
C'est une conférence
à destination des magiciens et des mentalistes.
On est censé tourner dans 5 minutes
comme vous pouvez voir tout est bien prêt... (ironie)
*Rire*
(Voix de loin) QUEL SALOP !
Et ça c'est Olivier, ça c'est le fou qui a eu l'idée de faire ça.
Ce qui savait pas c'est qu'on viendraient !
O: Fou c'est bien le terme, fou c'est bien le mot
O: Mais pour l'instant tout est secret donc c'est normal personne n'est au courant
On va parler de mémoire, de calculs
de toute ces petites choses
qu'on aime bien.
Tellement secret qu'en fait c'est un entrepôt désaffecté...
Tu vois le truc...
Faut pas donner l'adresse, faut pas donner l'adresse.
Faut pas dire que c'est au 28 rue de la république
AH MERDE !
Après un retard d'un peu près 2 heures
Et euh...
et des petits soucis techniques et tout
la conférence à enfin terminée !
Et puis, et puis voilà !
C'est tout ce que j'avais à dire !
Plus tôt dans la journée je vous ai mis une question
sur les réseaux sociaux, répondez-y
c'est vraiment important. C'est pour la vidéo de jeudi.
Je veux la faire en fonction de vos réponses.
Donc n'hésitez pas à aller voir sur Facebook, Twitter, Instagram, Snapchat, tout ça.
Je propage la question partout
partout, partout, partout.
J'espère que ce lundi a bien commencé pour vous.
Passez une très bonne semaine, à demain à 17 heures
pour le MentalVlog. Une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an !
Ciao !